ryan gosling  is an extremely talented actor from his  work in half nelson  to crazy stupid love to drive the man  can pretty much do any type of genre  flawlessly he's cool he's calm suave  he's got swag a man's man a woman's man  little girl's dream boy he's a man that  a little boy aspires to be he's got the  most relaxed shoulders  the most beautiful blue eyes that hair  oh that hair  you can feel all his internal emotions  the thoughts running through his mind  all the emotional depth without him  having to say a single word  that's talent [ __ ] the ladies  love him men don't call him gay  he's got that cool accent you want to  get out of here let's get out of here  let's get out of here you want to get  out of here who the [ __ ] would say no to  that watch him in interviews you'll like  him even more he's the reason i'm  watching  gangster squad